rapidement bon j accueille maintenant et
les and roll et jackie bonsoir
comment ça va ça va et toi bats toi voix
super super ouais ouais
hélène ça va très bien vers une feuille
qu'on s'est vus oui alors j'ai un petit
truc justement pour tous les deux pour
les deux un bon monsieur
c'est un lieu où vous tirez vous c'était
limite
et vous oui oui on fait semblant de vous
voyez on est la télé tu permets que je
te vois alors ouais tu permets que je te
vois bien alors il n' roll bonsoir dont
110 en dire aux lettres mais qui reste à
la fin il ya un accent grave sans le
dakar c'est tout on voulait l'avoir dit
un truc ça fat boys n'ont ni boles alors
toujours cassé les donc vous participez
au feuilleton les vacances de l'amour
qui est tourné fin novembre jusqu'à fin
décembre à saint martin oui je vais y
participer encore fait lui à l'ouragan
lenny là oui j'allais toujours d'accord
et diffusion février 2000 je le dis pour
les amis d'hélène qui sont nombreux un
album en cours d'écriture
oui sortie printemps 2000 alors est ce
que c'est que cette nouvelle énergie
vous vient de votre nouveau fiancé parce
que j'ai à nouveau financées par son
amant vincent
j'ai commencé assez jeune quand vous
étiez enfant vous étiez prêté par votre
maman avec votre soeur sophie comme
demoiselle d'honneur des mariannes sais
pas si c'est pas beau ça à prêter non
enfin oui on allait en allait avoir
moins de dire le contraire de tout ce
que je vais dire ça me dérange pas j'ai
l'habitude non vraiment vous prêter pour
être demoiselle d'honneur dans des
mariages légaux famille la famille quand
même là ce n'était pas des gens tu vois
ça oui vous initier les clodettes à la
perfection
en fait j'étais fan de claude françois
fans oui on a tous été je te les chars
d'amitié bien aussi cette année sur wii
fait plus ça c'est fini
pas de pot et alors vous avez un coup de
bol absolument incroyable désir cordon
rustique mal en lui un coup de bol est
absolument incroyable
en soixante dix huit votre mémé qu'il
piquait plus la main et les poulettes
paul être votre mémé elle lit le journal
paulette et elle voit qu'on cherche pour
un film ses moutons noirs de moscardo
avec dutronc une fille avec les yeux
bleus oui voilà
et comme vous aimez beaucoup elle vous a
quand même conseillé d'y aller vous avez
gagné 3000 candidate et vous avez gagné
le concours bien que n'ayant pas les
yeux le premier coup de chance ouais
gros coup de chaud deuxième puissance
cpu journal sur 5000 candidats des
concertos la deuxième coup de chance
votre maman organise au mans un concert
pour dorothée way entre autres à
l'organiser depuis un an des concerts
voilà tout et vous parce que j'étais
avant c'est vrai c'est tout musical
dorothée et moi même avant j'utilisais
reprend l allaine voilà c'était on est à
dix roses et la plongée elle m'a serré
dans le catering mais vous rencontré
jean-luc allouche azoulay qui deviendra
votre mentor ou sur les deux sets
laissez vous avez fait dans la salle
vide tous les deux et je me souviens
vous souvenez ouais c'est pas si vieux
je vais jouer quoi j'ai pas joué et
chanté
vous avez chanté quoi des chansons
dorothée changer quoi pourquoi mais
c'est une chanson de dorothée gens qu
elles étaient quelques-unes bah oui mes
nièces et mes petits cousins et cousines
alors voilà deux coups de chance
absolument incroyable coup sur coup
le journal de paulette l'audition avec
jean luc azoulay et vous voilà lancés
dans mais c'est vrai c'est incroyable
moi je me suis toujours très intéressé
de savoir comment les gens quel a été le
déclic
le la boîte angoulême pour fabrice
luchini non mais c'est vrai ça fait
d'ailleurs un moment important dans les
initiants c'est la difficulté qu'on a
mis à mettre en branle et c'était ce qui
était à mon avis le plus beau c'est
cette difficulté et ça c'est une chose à
laquelle je reviens de mec qu'a pas
compris que cette rencontre
cette rencontre du même type oui vous
savez au début de l'émission chère
madame monsieur thierry ardisson c'est
nous on est là depuis quand même pas mal
de nez dans une espèce de lâcher prise
c'est dire que les il ya de la bande aux
gens et postures dégrade pas vous avez
remarqué ce coup ci c'est vrai je vais
arriver dans la rétractation parce que
ça il faut savoir que j'arrive toujours
dans une inquiétude est que notre ami
laurent avait pointé juste retiré juste
et toujours au début je ne ramène pas
les choses à moi je fais une ombre dans
la difficulté
un peu de réactions ce qui est bien
normal comme vous au début et puis après
il ya dilatation il ya d'amour vous avez
compris lavaur attraction du natation et
la cdc qui mais là maintenant on est
dans une espèce de plus rien avant un
endroit vraiment je n'ai jamais rarement
laissé place aux spectacles sont prévus
vous arrivez dans un climat de profonde
de passion presque de deir ez on ne sait
plus trop comment s'appelle
hérarchie son calme et plus personne ne
sait combien l'eau de gan
on sait plus qui est qui on sait qu'il
ya des sportifs de très haut niveau on
les devine on sent qu'ils ont et le
physique et le génie de grands ennemis
et on sait qu'ils sont mariés avec la
yougoslavie ne faut pas l'emmerder trop
c'est qu'alain chabat est là et que est
que nous sommes tous là qu'il ya eu
rencontre entre mais il ya eu un truc
vous arrivez dans ce climat les
émissions normal je vous dis non je vous
dis émission je vous dis un mot
habituellement épouvantable lâcher prise
bon alors on continue à en continu tous
les deux bah oui oui on est seul au
monde encore 87 premiers 45 tours 89
premier album 91 premier baiser enfin la
série et 92 92
vous vous souvenez des améliorations du
samoa cemetery j'en ai parlé très
longtemps dans une émission domaines de
la société comme a marqué nomen de
société la ln magna ça ça existait 600
épisodes 6 millions de fans
l étau serge